la première autopsie que vous ayez
pratiqué sous votre propre
responsabilité c'était quand c'était
laquelle la mort tous les jours la mort
banalisée pense-t-on encore à la mort
quand enve et travail dans ces couloirs
de l'Institut médicau légal de Lyon la
morue à Lyon il existe une vieille
tradition de médecine légale le
professeur la Cassagne fut un des
pionniers de cette discipline où le
médecin est autant médecin que détective
le docteur David est l'un des
successeurs du grand
homme ça fait combien de temps docteur
que vousmême vous vous fréquenter les
morts ah ça fait plus de 20 ans
maintenant ça fait 24 ans exactement et
des milliers de morts alors des milliers
de morts oui bien sûr pourquoi avez-vous
choisi cette discipline oh pourquoi j'ai
choisi cette discipline parce qu'elle
m'a intéressé très tôt et que
effectivement j'ai eu un maître qui m'a
beaucoup intéressé dans cette discipline
et j'ai continué avec lui h malgré la
mort malgré les cadavres malgré oui
malgré la mort malgré les cadavres vous
savez c'est pas si impressionnant qu'on
veut bien le dire parce que euh d'abord
ça ne représente qu'une petite partie de
notre activité ça représente moins de 10
% de notre activité et puis il y a un
élément d'abord c'est une recherche
c'est une recherche très intéressante
savoir de quoi les gens sont morts et
puis il y a un aspect aussi un aspect
qui est très intéressant c'est le
contact avec les familles il faut quand
même pas oublier que nous voyons des
gens qui sont morts de mort violente ce
qui représente pour les familles un
deuil très important quelque chose de
considérable on a vu plus important
encore plus important qu'une mort
j'allais dire naturelle de maladie où
quelqu'un peut progressivement
s'habituer à la mort de celui qui lui
est cher tandis que là ces gens meurent
très brutalement et il faut avoir un
contact avec eux et c'est là si vous
voulez un des aspect je trouve très
intéressant de notre institut où il y a
dans cet institut une une assistante
sociale pour enseigner immédiatement les
familles pour essayer de leur faire
comprendre la mort du sujet et après et
bien ces personnes ces familles viennent
nous voir où nous nous leur donnons
systématiquement toutes les explications
qu'ils veulent un mdecin légist c'est un
détective aussi non oh c'est un grand
mot c'est quentendu un détective non en
fait il faut très bien faire son travail
le mieux possible et au cours de
l'autopsie on va pouvoir découvrir
beaucoup d'éléments beaucoup de choses
et ces choses que l'on va découvrir la
cause de la mort il doit falloir oublier
plein de choses quand même bon l'aspect
du cadavre les odeurs tout ça il y a
plein de choses désagréables enfin qu'
qu'on imagine imine en tout cas
l'extérieur de façon très désagréable
oui c'est vrai que c'est pas le côté le
plus attirant l'odeur du cadavre c'est
vrai dans quelques cas mais c'est
découvrir il faut découvrir il faut
rechercher vous imaginez vous la quand
vous
avez un sujet sur la table là vous
imaginez sa vie ce qu'il a été
ou c'est quelqu'un
d'anonyme non c'est quelqu'un d'anonyme
dans la plupart des cas bien sûr
difficile d'imaginer c'est sur un
cadavre difficile imaginer qui c'est et
c'est délicat et vous avez envie
d'imaginer ou pas ou ça ne vous
intéresse pas t ça autre si envie
d'imaginer qu'est-ce que ça représente
pas un type qui éé fait un coup de
revolver là c'est peut-être oui oui
effectivement on peut avoir envie
d'imaginer de temps en temps mais c'est
ça correspond pas bien à au travail que
nous faisons nous av un travail qui est
j' dire très scientifique qui est
extrêmement qui a une rigueur et dès que
que on imagine ben on a déjà plus
beaucoup de beaucoup moins de rigueur et
c'est per l'objectivité oui certain la
première autopsie que vous ayez pratiqué
sous votre propre responsabilité c'était
quand c'était laquelle 58 je l'ai oublié
vous l'avez oublié oui je l'ai oublié
celle-là bien sûr on peut l'oublier la
oh oui on peut l'oublier parce que ça
n'était pas la première autopsie que je
faisais c'était la première autopsie que
je faisais sous ma propre
responsabilité alors j'ai oublié
celle il y a eu des personnages de
médecin légistes très très célèbr même
un peu presque folcllorique oui bien sûr
bien sûr ce qui est actuellement plus
possible je crois alors autrefois il y
avait ces gens qui étaient oui c'est ça
je vois très bien qui parler docteur
Paul c'était un homme oui c'est vrai qui
était même assez folcllorique l'humour
le rire ça doit aider à mieux faire
passer les choses mour oui le rire
devant un cadavre on n jamais bien envie
de rire ou jamais après oui peut-être
après effectivement mais devant c'est
c'est toujours difficile si vous veniez
enfin dans nos salle d'autopsie si vous
venez voir une autopsie vous verrez que
effectivement personne ne pleure mais il
y a un respect du cadavre quoi qu'il en
soit et s'il est difficile de passer
outre et en fait je pense que quelqu'un
qui passerait outre serait assez mal vu
mais mal vu par le médecin par les gar
tout le me par tous ceux qui sont là et
qui font l'autopsie que ça soit les
garçons de salle que ça soit le médecin
ce soit pas de plaisanterie de Carabin
non c'est terminé ça oh c'est terminé la
plaisanterie de Carabin elle existe
toujours au moment dans les amphithéat
d'anatomie où l'on dis sait que on a 18
ans et c'est la présanterie de Carabin
après se
terminé mais quand même quand vous
sortez
d'ici vous plaisantez volontiers avec
les gens oui bien sûr
je pense que je suis un caractère très
et que le fait de faire des autopsies
pour modifier mon caractère et ne m'a
pas rendu ni
tre des autopsies plus plus angoissant
quand même que les autres peut-être oui
je pense qu'en particulier on a toujours
remarqué les autopsies d'enfant sont
plus angoissantes un enfant c'est pas
fait pour
mourir toujours toujours une certaine
difficulté de la part de tout le monde
oui vous arrivé d'opsier des gens que
vous connaissiez oui ça doêre terrible
ça difficile
oui difficile et nous sommes
actuellement suffisamment nombreux pour
ne pas faire ce genre d'autopsie si nous
connaissons quelqu'un nous demandons
qu'on nous décharge de de
l'autopsie est-ce qu'on peut s'habituer
à la mort est qu'on peut
s'habituer à vivre avec la mort parce
que que vous soyez là ou dans votre
laboratoire c'est toujours la mort qui
est en question
oui je pense pas qu'on puisse le poser
en ces terme est-ce qu'on peut
s'habituer à la mort oui bien sûr on
peut considérer que la mort c'est un
phénomène normal et oui c'est un
phénomène absolument normal la mort
qu'on s'y habitue en la trouvant
négligeable certainement pas
certainement pas
non vous pensez parfois à votre mort
quand vous êtes
ici oui que un jour ou l'autre alors die
merci on n pense pas tous les jours mais
un jour ou l'autre on pense à la mort
vous savez plus on vieillit pu on plus
on s'aperçoit que les gens dont on fait
l'autopsie arrivent à votre âge et que
il est évident que il y a 20 ans lorsque
je faisais une autopsie de quelqu'un qui
avait mon âge aujourd'hui et je dis
toujours moi qui avait l'âge de mon
patron de ce temps-là je disait à mon
patron oh c'est à peu près c'est normal
il est mort à cet âge là et mon patron
c'est pas normal c'est vrai c'est pas
normal et moi aujourd'hui je considère
que c'est pas normal de mourir à cet âge
là effectivement je pense c'est une
c'est une question de génération quoi
êtes-vous parfois lassé par ce métier
non non pas du tout absolument pas je
trouve que c'est très intéressant on a
une formation j'allais dire continue
c'est-à-dire que bien qu'on ait fait
beaucoup d'autopsie on découvre toujours
quelque chose de nouveau il y a toujours
un élément particulier à découvrir puis
il y a toujours des recherches à faire
qu'elle soit d'ailleurs simplement
d'ordre tamatologique pour la mort
elle-même ou d'un ordre thérapeutique
faut quand même bien savoir que si
aujourd'hui les accidents de la
circulation les traumatismes crâniens
très sévères meurent beaucoup moins
qu'il y a 20 ans c'est qu'on a fait
beaucoup d'autopsies ces gens-là et
qu'on s'est aperçu qu'est-ce qu'il
fallait faire quelles sont les notions
thérapeutique qu'il faut peut-être faire
évoluer la mort sert à la vie oui oui
bien sûr la mort sert à la vie c'est je
pense que c'est un des caractères très
importants de l'intérêt de ces autopsies
l'intérêt de ces autopsies et est de
temps en temps de dire et bien il
faudrait peut-être faire ceci ou cela et
modifier un peu les possibilités
thérapeutiques oui bien
sûr est-ce que les les les morts sont
encore pour vous quelquefois des enfin
des gens qui ont vécu est-ce que ou ce
sont simplement non c'est toujours
quelqu'un qui a vécu vous savez c'est
toujours un homme c'est toujours une
femme
[Musique]
on n pas cette idée quelquefois quand
tous les gens de cette espèce de coupure
immédiate au moment de la mort et
effectivement la mort c'est toujours
encore une
personne vous en parlezir en rentrant
chez
vous quelquefois oui oui quelquefois
j'ai la chance d'avoir une femme qui est
médecin aussi
alors oui c'est plus facile des
possibilités il faut en parler à votre
avis vous avez besoin d'en
parler je ne pense pas que j'ai souvent
besoin d'en parler peut-être quelquefois
oui besoin d'en parler un cas très
particulier une chose que je n'ai jamais
vu quelque chose d'exceptionnel oui
peut-être besoin d'en parler si vous
n'aviez pas été médecin légiste quelle
quelle discipline en médecine
auriez-vous exercé en discipline que je
exercé je pense celle que à laquelle je
me destinais départ j'étais de formation
de gynécologie et
d'accouchementis j'aiblqué
entre s'occuper des morts et mettre au
monde des enfants c'est vrai c'est vrai
l'alpha l'oméa oui
[Musique]
oui